keeping it close from the Congress of
the United States and they did so now
they did it classified in from a
presentation yesterday which their own
party members Republican senators said
it was the most demeaning and worse
classified briefing that they had had I
myself think they're stiff competition
for that designation of worst
presentation by this administration in a
classified briefing but all is that to
say is the Constitution of the United
States calls for there to be cooperation
when we decide about initiating
hostilities Congress has the right to
declare war when do you decide that it
is war when do you decide it's just
hostilities when does that all end what
line do you cross but with the
president's actions last week he
endangered our servicemen and women our
diplomats and others by taking a serious
risk of escalation with tensions of air
with Iran this does not come with any
respect for Iran we know what bad actors
they are in the world we know that
sulemani I from my intelligence
background know that sulemani was
somebody that we do not mourn the loss
of a bad - he did very evil things in
the world but we also know that when we
take an action we have to understand the
ramifications of it of it others could
have taken some money out Israel
could have taken soleimani out but they
didn't but they didn't so it that's
happened that's where it is as we go
forward it was really important for us
to address the parameters of the War
Powers Act and that is what we are doing
here today the members of Congress have
serious and urgent concerns about the
administration's a decision to engage I
use the term decision loosely to engage
in hostilities against Iran and it's
about a lack of strategy what is the
strategy
to move forward again I did not consult
with Congress they gave a class of a
presentation that by their own side of
the aisle has been described as
demeaning and the worst and then they
tell members to go read the classified
documents classified why are these
documents classified why can't the
American people now we understand
redaction of sources and methods and the
rest but if you read that document you
would know there is no reason for it to
be classified and in there without going
into any substantive matters of what
happened yesterday in the classified
briefing it's fair to say that we were
told members were told to go read other
documents which are redacted and in many
cases classified unnecessarily our
concerns were not addressed by the
president's insufficient War Powers
authorization which was classified in
its entirety leaving that Congress in
the public in the dark about our
national security and our concerns were
not addressed by the president the
administration's briefing yesterday
today to honor our duty to keep the
American people safe that is our first
responsibility to protect and defend we
must keep the American people safe the
house will pass a War Powers Resolution
to limit the president's military
actions regarding Iran Congress is
reassuring our long-established
oversight responsibilities as we mandate
that if no further congressional action
is taken the administration's military
hostilities with regard to Iran must end
we salute congresswoman Slavkin for her
leadership in this resolution she's a
former CIA and Department of Defense
analyst specializing in Shia militias
who served multiple tours in the region
under both Democratic and Republican
presidents it's important to know
because I heard the distinguished whip
on the other side of the aisle say how
come you it's just a a concurrent
resolution it is because under the War
Powers
that is one of the options that is
provided can do a joint resolution house
resolution or you can do a concurrent
resolution the value and the beauty and
the exquisite nature of a concurrent
resolution is that it does not have to
be signed by the President of the United
States the Congress of the United States
and this full power and full voice can
speak in a United Way about what the War
Powers Act should look like and that
should count for something to our
colleagues who serve in the Congress of
the United States and so under the
authority of the War Powers Act that
gives us this option we take this
opportunity to do so but I implore the
administration to work with Congress to
advance immediate effective
de-escalatory strategy that prevents
further violence I also salute this
resolution because it does give
opportunity for the administration to
act under certain circumstances which
are part of the War Powers Act madam
Speaker on December a group of us in a
bipartisan way we travel to Belgium and
Luxembourg to observe the 75th
anniversary of the Battle of the Bulge
some of our colleagues on both sides of
the aisle had family members who served
in that battle one of ours and it Custer
her father served in that and she has
letters from him at that time and other
members on both sides of the aisle mr.
Moulton Seth Moulton his grandfather
served in battle before but also on the
Republican side of the aisle in the
house and in the Senate and why I bring
it up is this because that battle that
balls was the decisive battle in World
War two was a surprise attack really by
the Germans it was a bloody battle we
lost 19,000 Americans
19,000 Americans in that Battle of the
Bulge when I was listening to the
description of it on the days that we
were there from the veterans who served
it sounded almost like Washington
Crossing the Delaware because
it was December as it was in the United
States at the beginning of our and fight
for independence their supplies were
insufficient the camouflage for snow was
not adequate our veterans our member
then men in uniform were exposed nurses
too and it was a triumph that decided
that was very decisive in World War two
and I bring it up is because when there
was the observance of it for three days
with parts of three days we were there
for it but the clothes of it there was a
ceremony that included a speech by the
president excuse me the king of Belgium
the Grand Duke of Luxembourg who were
the places where this all took place the
president of Germany who spoke
beautifully about Germany now and saying
when you've freed Luxembourg and Belgium
you also freed the Germans what a
beautiful statement but the clothes of
it was from a veteran who served in the
Battle of the Bulge in his 90s was a
teenager in the war we saw the foxholes
in which they fought they lost their
love their their comrades in arms he
talked about the the Brotherhood and he
talked about allies and he talked about
the fight and at the end of the speech
the veterans said I don't know if I
should say this but I will my message to
all of you is pray for peace pray for
peace that's what we should be doing is
moving toward peace not escalation of
hostilities where that can be avoided
not because we believe there's that the
other side has good motive
stations or that's all our money was not
a bad person
it's not because of what they are it's
because of who we are as Americans a
country that is committed to peace and
security and prepared to protect and
defend as President Kennedy said fight
any fight fight any foe pay any price to
keep the American people safe but to not
be frivolous and cavalier about how we
decide to show strength when it really
is more of an escalation than a
de-escalation so it's sad because you
would think that any time we would
engage in such an important change in
approach that we would be working
together consulting together respecting
the approach that each side takes to all
of this and hopefully just be on one
side of it all so I think this is a very
important it doesn't do our reimburse
you said well it doesn't do this it
doesn't do that we should never be
judging legislation for necessarily for
what it doesn't do but respecting it for
what it does do and what this does is
very important for the security of our
country
urge a yes vote and yield back the
balance of my time gentleman from New
York reserves the gentleman from Texas
is recognized
I'm speaker I'm pleased to yield one
minute to the gentleman from Alabama the
ranking member of the Homeland Security
Committee mr. Rogers the gentleman is
recognized
thank you madam Speaker and I think the
ranking member I rise in strong
opposition to this brazen political
stunt Kasim Soleimani was a vicious
terrorist who built a cult following on
the backs of dead americans he armed
Hezbollah k/h and other Iranian proxies
who killed American troops and our
allies throughout the Middle East the
Homeland Security and Defense
Department's have kept close watch on
his terror campaigns for years Soleimani
was not visiting Baghdad because it was
a great holiday destination
he was there to meet the leader of a
terrorist group that killed an American
just days before our president used the
law and his constitutional authority as
commander-in-chief to eliminate this
terrorist mastermind before he could
kill again
Democrats immediately responded by
doubting our intelligence and dismissing
the expertise of our military leaders
now they bring this resolution to the
floor that maligns our president
undermines our national security and
makes a martyr of a man who killed
nearly 600 Americans
I urge a no vote and yield back
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized
I now yield two minutes to the Majority
Whip the gentleman from South Carolina
mr. Clyburn gentleman from South
Carolina is recognized thank you very
much and I thank my friend for yielding
the time speaking out against the
Vietnam War in 1967 dr. Martin Luther
King jr. implored we must move past
indecision to action we must find new
ways to speak for peace if we do not act
we shall surely be dragged down the long
dark and shameful corridors of time
reserved for those who possess power
without compassion might without
morality and strength without sight not
the King's words are just as apropos
today President Trump in Orland and
significant military strike against
authorization for or without seeking
authorization or even consultations that
Congress has brought us to the brink of
war the Constitution of this great
country gives a solemn power to declare
war to the people's representatives in
Congress not one person in the White
House whoever that might be with this
resolution Congress has acted to uphold
our constitutional responsibility if the
President believes military action
against Iran is warranted
this resolution and the Constitution
require him to make the case to Congress
and receive authorization mr. speaker
are truly regret that we find ourselves
in the position we are today the Trump
administration's policy toward Iran
abandoning the nuclear deal rather than
building on it while escalating tensions
instead is an unwise application of
American power might and strength the
strike against generals suleimani a bad
man who no American mourns drags us
closer to another long dark and shameful
corridor to an unnecessary war our ears
he adopted the resolution now a year
back the balance of my time
gentleman from New York reserves
gentleman from Texas is recognized mr.
speaker I'm pleased to yield one minute
to the gentleman from California mr.
McClintock gentleman from California is
recognized
Thank You mr. speaker our Constitution
is clear that only Congress can start a
war but only the president can wage it
Congress started this war with the AUMF
in 2002 it's still in effect the
founders didn't want one individual
getting us into a war but once in it
they didn't want 535 squabbling prima
donnas second-guessing every decision on
the battlefield President Trump needed
no other reason to order the attack that
killed Salamone in Iraq beyond the
simple fact that he was acting as an
enemy combatant against US forces in a
war zone in which the Congress had
authorized the President to take
military action now I happen to believe
the AUMF was a colossal mistake but this
resolution doesn't correct that mistake
it compounds it by deliberately
undermining the position of the United
States government and the armed forces
that we sent to Iraq at a perilous
moment which makes it not only
unconstitutional but disgraceful I yield
back the gentleman from Texas reserves
gentleman from New York
is recognized I yield one minute to the
vice chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee the chair of the Subcommittee
on Oversight and investigations the
gentleman from Texas mr. Castro general
from Texas is recognized Thank You mr.
speaker in the last few days the
American people have been unwillingly
taken to the brink of war at the
direction of this administration through
reckless actions the White House has
unified the Iranian public alienated our
partners in Iraq and Europe undermine
the fight against Isis and let the
United States more isolated than before
all in just one week and without the
consent of this Congress this is a grave
and serious moment in our country two
days ago
our brave men and women in uniform came
under fire from 22 Iranian missiles in
harm's way because of their
commander-in-chief every American was a
debt of gratitude to our military for
its courage and sacrifice for that
reason a decision that risk troops
well-being must only be made
thoughtfully and with the informed
consent of the public and this Congress
as a member of Congress my biggest
priority is to protect the safety of the
American people at home and abroad this
can only be done by defending Congress's
constitutional authority over declaring
war and for that reason I urge us to
support this resolution gentleman from
New York reserves the gentleman from
Texas is recognized the Speaker I yield
one minute to the gentleman from
Louisiana mr. Abraham gentleman from
Louisiana is recognized
Major Ronald Culver Jr copal Justin
Mixon sergeant Joseph Prashad the third
sergeant Terrell Gilmore
Staff Sergeant Jarid Fontenot corporal
William crouch private mark Graham Staff
Sergeant Ronnie Sanders
Staff Sergeant Jarid macmillan sergeant
Joshua went
star jet Tiger through private Joshua
burrows corporal Joseph directorís Lance
Corporal John Bowman Lance Corporal John
Hale sergeant Matthew Westman sergeant
first class Terry Wallace sergeant
Murray testers Lance Corporal Derek
column
Staff Sergeant Brian Lewis sergeant
Julia julen Atkins sergeant william
partridge corporal David Stewart so
thirty seconds is shown thirty seconds
is Gwen sergeant David Murray First
Sergeant Michael borderline sergeant
nicholas oliver sergeant Seth Trahan
Staff Sergeant Jonathan Reed Staff
Sergeant Christopher Ramsey sergeant
Michael Evans sergeant Robert Sweeney
Staff Sergeant William Manuel and mr.
chairman are mr. I requesting Madison's
consent to enter the rest of my
testimony into the record without
objection gentleman from Texas reserves
General from New York is recognized
I now yield one minute to a valued
member of the Foreign Affairs Committee
the gentlewoman from Pennsylvania mr.
Lahan gentleman from Pennsylvania is
recognized
Thank You mr. chair
Mr Speaker I rise in support of the
resolution before us today article 1
section 8 of the Constitution states
quote Congress shall have the power to
declare war end quote
the founders were unequivocal only
Congress has the power to authorize acts
of war today we bring forth this
resolution to honor our founding fathers
vision for our country for our
government one whose very survival
hinges on the separation of powers and
each branch's respect for the others
Authority at this moment we as a
Congress have an opportunity to pursue
de-escalatory actions that protect the
lives of our armed forces
lamotte's and civilians and I implore
the President and this administration to
work with this Congress in this effort
today marks this first step we must
aggressively pursue diplomacy so that no
lives are lost I encourage all of my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle to
join in that pursuit I urge my
colleagues to support this resolution
I urge a yes vote I yield back the
gentleman reserves gentleman from New
York reserves gentleman from Texas is
recognized the speaker I'm pleased deal
one and a half minutes to the gentleman
from Michigan mr. Walberg gentleman from
Michigan is recognized
thank you the ranking member and Thank
You mr. Speaker I rise today in strong
support of a president who carried out
his oath of office
I'm afraid the reason we are here today
again is out of pure opposition to this
president and not the serious national
security issues at hand
make no mistake terrorists Salamone
is responsible for the deaths of
hundreds of Americans including those
that my friend and colleague Ralph
Abraham just read hundreds of Americans
and he was plotting to kill many more
the president used his full legal
authority to take defensive action and
eliminate this brutal terrorists the
world is safer today because of it in
times like these we need to come
together as a country and stand in
behind our men and women in uniform who
off ever occupies the White House should
have the ability to direct and address
threats and prevent American bloodshed
just 48 hours ago Iran attacked US
military personnel and yet we are
hastily voting on this partisan
resolution that will weaken national
security I urge my colleagues
to vote no on this political show
resolution and I yield back
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized I now yield
one minute to the gentlewoman from Ohio
miss Kaptur gentlewoman from Ohio is
recognized
I thank the gentleman for yielding and
rise in support of the War Powers
Resolution as an original co-sponsor
this is a grave and pivotal moment in
American history and we must be greatly
concerned for the security of our troops
and the safety of the American people we
live in an era of hybrid warfare and
high intensity reaction one reckless
military strike can incentivize
countermeasures not just in the
immediate region but thousands of miles
away by Iran's proxies wise use of force
matters without congressional
authorization and in defiance of our
Constitution this president ordered an
unprecedented strike on Iran's top
generals there is no doubt soleimani was
a fierce enemy of Liberty however this
lone ranger attacked by the president
risks all-out war greater instability in
Iraq and Iran losing the edge we have
gained at such great cost and some of
those names have been put on the record
today we must protect against further
attacks on our servicemembers and
attacks on US assets wherever they might
exist might I have an additional 15
seconds gentlewoman I request additional
15 seconds may proceed thank you to
those ends the American people deserve
full transparency the president must
take steps to de-escalate this highly
volatile situation in the most uncover
nerble part of the world
let us rigorously pursue with our allies
turning back Iran's development of
nuclear weapons and let us do all we can
to uphold our beloved Constitution put
raging bulls back in their cages and
make the American people safer I yield
back
gentleman from New York reserves young
man from Texas is recognized
they were speaker I'm pleased to yield
two minutes to the gentleman from the
great state of Texas mr. Arrington
from Texas is recognized I think my
friend and fellow Texan ranking member
mr. McCall for his strong leadership mr.
speaker it's one thing to weaponize
impeachment to discredit the president
it's a whole nother thing to handcuff
our commander-in-chief and jeopardize
the safety of our soldiers and prevent
them from defending themselves
thankfully this is a partisan resolution
that's going nowhere but it's also
disturbing insight into the naive and
impotent ideology of appeasement that
invited Russia into Syria created Isis
in Iraq and embolden Iran to terrorize
and brutally murder throughout the
Middle East this is not a resolution
this is a retreat a de facto apology but
for what for ridding the world of a
brutal terrorists with American blood on
his hands if this resolution were to
become law mr. speaker it would be a
death warrant and not for the worst of
terrorists but for the best of Americans
our sons and daughters on the
battlefield who would be left
defenseless sitting ducks for a
murderous mob of mullahs in Iran and
iranian-backed militias throughout the
region I urge a no vote and I yield back
the gentleman from Texas reserves the
gentleman from New York is recognized I
yield one minute to the gentlewoman from
Illinois mr. Kowski the gentlewoman from
Illinois is recognized it is past time
for Congress to exert our authority over
the questions of war and peace and I am
proud to vote for this concurrent
resolution to invoke the War Powers Act
in order to restrain this reckless
president this vote would halt military
operations and force the president to
come to Congress to authorize any
further acts of war the president
remarkably said all is well well mr.
president is not well Iran announced
that it would withdraw from the nuclear
agreement and will begin to resume its
nuclear weapons plan the United States
has
has been forced to stop its actions
against Isis Iraq is likely to expel the
United States from its country
fulfilling what has been a dream
actually of sulemani our European allies
are angry because they were not alerted
and our actions have United the people
of Iraq against us and Iran two are
together now mr. president America is
not safer because of what you've done
this resolution members are reminded to
direct their march to the chair the
gentleman from New York reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized
Mr Speaker I continue to reserve the
balance of my time gentleman from Texas
reserves gentleman from New York is
recognized it's now my pleasure to yield
the magic minute cause magic minutes are
wonderful - the majority leader of the
house the gentleman from Maryland mr.
Hoyer the gentleman from Maryland is
recognized I thank the gentleman for
yielding let us hope that demagoguery
will not play too great a part in the
consideration of this piece of
legislation just heard one of my
colleagues on the other side
mischaracterized the position of my
party and of this resolution this
resolution is the law this resolution is
consistent with not only the law the War
Powers Act but the Constitution of the
United States and I want to thank
representative slatkin for authoring
this resolution as well as chairman
Smith chairman Engel representative
Connor representative Lee and others who
have been working hard to ensure that
Congress maintains its role as a
co-equal branch of government when it
comes to matters of war and peace this
President as we have seen has can
assistant Li treated the legislative
branch as inferior to the executive said
the mr. speaker we've had numerous votes
on this floor last year to stand up for
the co-equal status of the Congress of
the United States and too often our
Republican friends have sided with the
executive department diminishing the
authority and the position of the
Congress of the United States this is
not about this president nor is it about
shrinking from confronting terrorism and
terrorists again and again we have seen
this president ignore Congress's
directives on appropriations including
by shifting money away from the military
to fund his costly and ineffective board
of wars he has refused to disperse
emergency funding for disaster relief
that Congress allocated to help the
people of Puerto Rico and other places
where Americans are in need of help and
he withheld congressionally appropriated
funding to help Ukraine repeal Russian
terrorism after criticizing his
predecessor for the use of executive
orders President Trump has doubled down
on using them to circumvent the will of
Congress and the American people all
this resolution is say mr. president
obey the law obey the Constitution of
the United States of America which gives
to the Congress the sole authority to
declare war and if you read the language
of the resolution it continues to say
that we are for certainly defending any
of our people at risk period the War
Powers Act provides for that article 2
of the Constitution provides for that
but the president is ignored
congressional subpoenas
for documents and testimony directly
subordinates to build a wall of
obstruction unseen in our history it
should therefore be no surprise that we
representatives of the 320 million plus
people of America who expect us to be
their voice in this critical issue of
declaring war and this resolution does
not prohibit in any way the President of
the United States under his Article two
powers acting to defend our military our
allies and our homeland
now when the actions taken last week he
is unilaterally moving us toward an
involvement in another deadly and
destabilizing war in the Middle East now
I'm glad very frankly that as we all are
that the response that came from Iran
was either ineffective or meant to be
simply a message I don't know which
thankfully however the Congress is under
law and our Constitution a remedy to
reassert our position as a co-equal
branch as a matter of fact or nautical
one branch ensure as the founders
intended that only the Congress speaking
on behalf of all of the people could
declare war Congress passed the War
Powers Act in 1973 because they believed
a Democratic president and it was a
Democratic Congress that adopted the War
Powers Act because they believed a
Democratic president had overstepped the
bounds Congress passed the War Powers
Act in 1973 determined to ensure that no
president can send our troops into war
without the people's representatives
authoring it I suggest to my friends on
both sides of the aisle that is what the
founders intended we must use this tool
of congressional power
or by our silence acquiesce to the
growth of the imperial presidency which
by the way has been going on for some
forty years maybe even 50 years
irrespective of who is president this is
not a partisan resolution this is a
resolution consistent with the
Constitution of the United States of
America who did not want a single person
to be able to take America to war to put
our men and women at risk let us be
absolutely clear kasam soleimani was a
dangerous purveyor of terror and
violence and a practice there up he was
an architect of Iranian efforts to
dominate the Middle East through
aggression and fear he has American
blood on his hands as well as the blood
of our allies he has met the justice he
deserves I say that notwithstanding the
fact I do not know from the information
that I have received whether or not in
fact it was absolutely essential to take
his life now because of eminent danger
perhaps it was but at any event no one
laments the loss of Salah Monty's life
at least in this country and
freedom-loving people throughout the
world and we are relieved that the
Iranian Counter Strike was limited and
caused no American or allied casualties
but Mr Speaker my constituents and the
American people are deeply concerned
about what comes next with a possibility
of further retaliation and escalation
from Iran or its proxies there may be a
time
action is called for but is this body
that needs to make that decision and the
United States Senate this body
it continues Iran is a dangerous enemy
of freedom and a sponsor of terror it
continues to harbor ambitions of
dominance over its neighbors and to call
for the destruction of Israel this
Iranian regime is no friend and must not
be trusted Iran must never be allowed to
acquire a nuclear weapon
I believe this Congress would vote to
ensure that that was prohibited this
resolution makes those facts clear we
must have a sound long-term strategy to
deal with Iran and bring it into
compliance with international laws and
norms the threat of military force must
continue to be a part of any strategy
along with sanctions and diplomacy and
this resolution in no way counter means
that premise the best way forward is for
Congress and the administration to work
together that's what our founders have
in mind
proper congressional oversight and
involvement will help ensure not
undermine that the administration adopts
and pursues the best possible strategy
to check and oppose Iran's malign
ambitions well it's not demagogue one
another there can be differences but
this resolution is brought to this floor
of the house to uphold the Constitution
of the United States of America and to
again urge this president as we have
urged Democratic presidents to
sure that they follow the strictures of
our constitution on behalf of the safety
of our people and there's respect we
have throughout the world we're a nation
of laws this resolution is about the
laws and I yield back the balance of my
time
gentleman from New York reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized
louia say have great respect for the
leader and I do not disagree with him
that the president needs to come to
Congress to authorize war with Iran but
that is not what we were looking at here
today we do not currently have troops
engaged in hostility in Iran subject to
withdrawal under the War Powers
Resolution however if the administration
were to strike Iran directly in my
opinion they would need to submit a War
Powers notification and we would they
would also need to proceed with an
authorized use of military force and
with that mr. speaker I'm pleased to
yield two minutes to the gentleman from
Florida mr. Spano gentleman from Florida
is recognized Thank You ranking member
McCall I oppose this resolution the
speaker claims that is a it is a
necessary response to president Trump's
quote disproportionate attack on a
high-level Iranian military official
disproportionate apparently Democrats
have forgotten who Qasem Soleimani was
one of the worst perpetrators of terror
in recent history he led the
organization that founded Hezbollah one
of the most violent terrorist groups
opposing Israel he directed his groups
to kill over 600 American servicemembers
in Iraq and wound thousands more he led
a brutal attack on peaceful protesters
recently in Iran killing over 1,000
Iranians a bully will not stand down
unless he knows you are willing to stand
toe-to-toe with him unless he knows
there are consequences to his actions
and president Trump acted decisively in
bringing down this brutal
inhumane bully this terrorist mastermind
to stop an eminent threat it was
necessary necessary to show Iran we will
no longer tolerate their aggression we
should be united in our support for
eliminating this threat and in
supporting the president's efforts to
negotiate a new more effective Iran deal
and I urge my colleagues to oppose this
resolution so that all options are on
the table and we can negotiate from a
position of strength toward achieving a
peaceful solution I yield back the
gentleman from Texas reserves the
gentleman from New York is recognized I
yield one minute to the gentlewoman from
California miss su gentleman from
California is recognized
I thank the gentleman Mr Speaker I rise
in strong support of this concurrent
resolution which requires President
Trump to immediately terminate military
operations against Iran it's about time
that Congress exercised its War Powers
Act powers authority under the
Constitution I believe this is long
overdue now the president has taken our
nation to the brink of war without
properly consulting Congress or seeking
the legal authority to do so only
Congress can authorize military action
under article 1 of the Constitution and
to add insult to injury the Trump
administration has failed to fully
explain to Congress and the American
people what exactly the imminent threat
was to the United States that required
the strike that was undertaken my
constituents and people across the
country have been terrified about the
prospect of a new war in the Middle East
now let me be clear no member of
Congress carries a brief for Soleimani
or the EOB gentlewoman an extra 15
seconds I thank you but no president has
unilateral authority to take our nation
to war without authorization from
Congress I urge my colleagues to vote
yes the gentleman from New York
reserves the gentleman from Texas is
recognized mr. speaker I'm pleased to
yield two minutes to the gentleman from
North Carolina mr. Bishop Javal from
North Carolina is recognized
I thank the ranking member mr. speaker
if it were but a matter of offering
three cheers for the legislative branch
that would be fine but this is dangerous
and simply makes no sense if the
majority wished to assert Congress's
authority as several have argued it
would not use a non-binding resolution
but let me take the majority at its
chosen words as if binding the words of
the resolution
would literally prohibit the president
from ordering the shoot-down of Iranian
ballistic missiles in bound for Haifa or
a surface-to-air missile locked on to a
Ukrainian airliner and the resolutions
chosen words as Democrats argue them
would prevent the president from the
strike on Soleimani itself even if
devastating harm to American soldiers
were imminent but Democrats
second-guessed that judgment the
language you have chosen is designed to
debilitate the president from protecting
Americans the intemperate words of the
past week have cost many their
credibility now Democrats fight for
president Trump has cost them their good
judgment I yield back
the gentleman from Texas reserves the
gentleman from New York is recognized I
yield one minute to the gentlewoman from
California miss Davis
the gentlewoman from California is
recognized Thank You mr. speaker mr.
speaker I voted against the 2002 AUMF in
coming to that very difficult decision I
learned an important lesson that we must
ask every administration that seeks to
use military force
how will it manage the consequences of
its actions even if those actions can be
justified
has this administration done that
unfortunately I think the answer is no I
will vote for this resolution today for
the same reasons I had been no overall
strategy no justification and nobody in
this administration can answer how how
it will respond to the aftermath by
virtue of the power and the
responsibility granted to us by the
Constitution we must ask those questions
let's take this opportunity to make
diplomacy work let's stand together as
the Congress to establish our authority
let's stand together and vote against a
new war without an end game are you bad
the gentleman from New York reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized your
speaker I'm pleased to yield two minutes
to the gentleman from Louisiana mr.
Abraham Jennifer from Louisiana is
recognized sergeant first class Kurt
como Sergeant Christopher babban
sergeant Bradley Bergeron sergeant Hugh
Fassbender sergeant Armand Fricke
sergeant Oren Murphy
sergeant Craig Nelson first lieutenant
Christopher Burnett private first class
Torrey densely private first class James
Lambert
sergeant Taft Williams I want to thank
the ranking member
chairman McCaul for giving me additional
time to finish the list that I started
earlier these are 44 young Americans
that died from Louisiana by IEDs in the
most active part of Iraq when Soleimani
and his proxies were engaged they
designed they built and they implemented
these IEDs and in Louisiana alone
forty-four young Americans gave their
lives for the United States of America
President Trump he had the authority he
has the right and thankfully he had the
courage to terminate Soleimani and
remove this cancer from this earth and
to my Democratic colleagues and friends
I say if you can look these gold star
families in the face and tell them that
this was not a justified strike and that
solemn and needed to be removed from
this earth then God have mercy on you I
yield back mr. speaker gentleman from
Texas reserves gentleman from New York
is recognized I yield one minute to a
valued member of the Foreign Affairs
Committee the gentleman from New Jersey
mr. Malinowski the gentleman from New
Jersey is recognized mr. speaker we may
be relieved that an impulsive act by
President Trump has not immediately led
to war with Iran we may be relieved that
an evil man is dead but as that evil man
wished our troops have now been asked to
leave Iraq and if they stay their
ability to work with Iraqis to fight
Isis has been shot as he wished the
protest movement in Iran and Iraq that
threatened the Iranian regime has been
silenced as he wished Iran is now
breaking free of all restrictions on its
nuclear program we are not safer today
and in this moment of danger there is
just one question that this resolution
asks not do you support what the
president has already done but should
Congress play our constitutional role in
deciding what happens next I support
this resolution because passing it will
protect us against going to war with a
tweet but it also ensures that if we do
go to war which we may have to at some
point we will do so with the American
people United not divided as the framers
intended
as our national interest demands I yield
back the gentleman from New York
reserves the gentleman from Texas is
recognized the speaker I continue to
reserve the balance of my time
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized I yield one
minute to the gentleman from California
mr. Cisneros gentleman from California
is recognized
mr. Speaker I rise today in defense of
our Constitution expressed the urgent
need of Congress to re-establish itself
as an equal branch of government
our founders explicitly laid out the
roles and responsibilities of the
legislative executive and judiciary
branches creating a necessary system of
checks and balances but today we find
our democratic system in jeopardy in the
past week there has been an increasing
concern about the United States going to
war with Iran let me be very clear if
and when president decides to use
military action he must go through
Congress first article 1 section 8 of
the Constitution gives Congress the
power to declare war any attempt to
undermine the power would be unsafe
unacceptable and unconstitutional as a
Navy veteran
I am constantly thinking of our brave
service members it's why I take this
constitutional responsibility seriously
we cannot turn our backs to our
principles we cannot turn our backs to
our values and we cannot turn our backs
to the Constitution I look forward to
voting for the War Powers Resolution and
taking Congress's power back I yield
back the balance of my time
the gentleman from New York reserves and
the gentleman from Texas is recognized
under speaker I'm pleased to yield two
minutes to the gentleman from Georgia
mr. heiss gentleman from Georgia is
recognized Thank You mr. speaker and my
good friend I rise it with great
frustration in opposition to this
politically motivated resolution it is
nothing but a blatant attempt to
handcuff the president's ability to
defend our citizens and our allies just
this morning US intelligence officials
reported that they are now confident
that the Ukraine airline 7:52 is shot by
I shot down by Iranian surface-to-air
missiles another 176 innocent lives lost
the Islamic Republic of Iran has been
hostile to our nation for decades and
yet it is certainly escalated in the
last several months with a campaign of
antagonistic military action have my
Democratic colleagues forgotten about
the shipping vessel sabotage by naval
mines last May in June where the
American drone shot down over
international waters where the British
oil tanker seized by the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard or the Saudi all
facilities that were attacked and then
when an American citizen was killed in
an attack on Kirkuk air base in December
and our embassy and Iraq subsequently
overrun our president drew a line in the
sand yet after months of tremendous
restraint the president was determined
that not one more American life would be
lost at this Iranian regime and I fully
support the president in his actions I
do agree with many of my colleagues that
it's time for this body to have a
serious conversation and to address the
many issues inherent with operating
under a twenty plus year old
authorization for military force but
that should not be confused with the
process that's taking place here with
this resolution this is nothing but
another attempt by the majority 15 be
happy to yield additional 30 seconds
John they may continue thank you this is
nothing but an attempt by the majority
and a three-year long process by their
party to take any and every opportunity
to undermine or embarrass this president
but be assured that this politically
motivated resolution nor any evil that
comes our way will cause our president
to hesitate when called upon to defend
American lies and I just say God bless
the president god bless america
and with that I yield back the gentleman
from Texas reserves the gentleman from
New York is recognized
well I would say to my friends on the
other side of the aisle please don't
question our motives or patriotism and
we won't question yours I now yield one
minute to the gentlewoman from
Washington miss ji pal the gentlewoman
from Washington is recognized Thank You
mr. speaker I rise in strong support of
this resolution that reasserts
congressional authority over going to
war we know this war is devastating for
our troops for their families for
families and children everywhere for not
just this generation but future
generations to come for our humanity and
that is why our framers gave this body
the opportunity the responsibility to
have that discussion and declare war
should it be needed in 2002 we rushed to
war based on made-up claims of weapons
of mass destruction and that Iraq war
and Afghanistan wars took hundreds of
thousands of lives created millions of
refugees and cost us trillions of
dollars today the president without
providing any raw intelligence to prove
an imminent threat has brought us to the
brink of war with Iran so this
resolution makes it clear that Congress
has not authorized this war we also must
repeal the 2002 AUMF and vote to
withhold funds for this unauthorized war
it is time to restock expired Authority
I yield back
gentleman from New York reserves
gentleman from Texas is recognized he
was Speaker I continue to reserve the
balance of my time
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized I yield one
minute to the gentlewoman from Michigan
mr. Lane the gentlewoman from Michigan
is recognized
Mr Speaker I rise today on behalf of 13
district strong this is a district that
believes in leading with compassion they
believe in a full stop to endless
violent wars that only result in loss of
life and the destruction of lives
forever changed for us mr. speaker it is
important to protect our democracy and
promote global
we must remove political motives and
for-profit schemes from the
decision-making process to go to war if
we don't it would only lead to more
warfare and death we cannot allow a
process that is tainted secretive or
encompasses lies to make that choice
we need a country that easily chooses
peace for generations to come
I proudly represent a district that
believes in the rule of law that is why
I rise today and as their voice in
support of a War Powers Resolution that
will give them a say in whether or not
our country goes to war thank you
when from New York reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized Thank
You speaker I'm pleased to yield three
minutes to the gentleman from Tennessee
mr. green gentleman from Tennessee is
recognized Thank You mr. Speaker I rise
in complete opposition to this
resolution first this is a non-binding
resolution if you really wanted to exert
some congressional decision-making we do
a bill that goes before the president
and gets signed or gets vetoed this is
purely theatrics
none of these Democrat leaders stood up
when President Obama violated the
airspace of Pakistan to take out Osama
bin Laden now I'm glad he did that but
he violated there was no congressional
authorization to go into Pakistan at
least here there's a congressional
authorization for our forces to be on
the ground and using military power the
president has clear authority under
Article two to act when our nation in
our military is at risk the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff said and I
quote the trigger for the drone strike
that killed Soleimani was clear
unambiguous intelligence indicating a
significant campaign of violence against
the United States in the days weeks and
months and that the administration would
have been culpably negligent if it did
not general mark Milley these people
understand one thing and its strength
you'll recall that when President
Clinton pulled our forces out of Somalia
after we got the black eye on on Black
Hawk Down
bin Laden cited that as a as proof that
the Americans run away that they won't
stand and fight I've been to combat
three times in this region of the world
twice in Iraq and once in Afghanistan
I've looked these individuals in the eye
it's strength that they understand and
clearly it's shown itself to be true
again this president stood up and Iran's
response was clear they had to audiences
in their response at home they they
wanted people to see strength they shot
15 missiles they're back in their press
saying they killed Americans they didn't
of course the other audience the United
States and the rest of the world they
fired 16 16 missiles all 16 missed all
16 missiles missed remember when they
hit Saudi Arabia all those missiles hit
they know how to hit their target they
fired 16 missiles against us and not a
one hit what's the message they're
saying immediately after they fired him
they stood him and said we're done no
more that's the end of our response they
told the Shia militia groups to stand
down and moqtada al-sadr said to his
people today stand down they respond to
strength and our president did the right
thing he was a strong response a strong
response to storming sovereign US
territory of an embassy with 6,000
people killing American contractors and
wounding American soldiers with a rocket
attack mr. speaker this president made a
strong response and it's shown itself to
work
I yield gentleman from Texas reserves
gentleman from New York is recognized
thank you I I just can't really believe
what I just heard there was the the 2001
AUMF specifically authorized are going
after Osama bin Laden he's the example
of Congress getting involved that was
the authorization to get a Somma bin
Laden in Pakistan or anyplace else and
that's what we're trying to assure here
that
things aren't just happening that there
was actual Authority and Osama bin Laden
is the wrong example because we gave the
authority to go after him I yield one
minute to a gentlewoman from Florida
miss Franco gentleman from Florida is
recognized Thank You mr. speaker
as a mother of a United States Marine
War veteran I came to Congress with the
promise of never sending someone else's
child to a war that could be avoided
this War Powers Resolution says no war
with Iran without congressional approval
while still ensuring defense if there's
an imminent threat while we do not mourn
the death of Iran's commander of Terror
Americans and our Ally's worry about the
ramifications will make us less safe the
fight against Isis has been diverted
regional protests against the Iranian
regime are now against America Iranian
proxies have been further incited and
Iran is closer to having a nuclear
weapon America is not a monarchy the
decision to go to war requires debate
deliberation and collective judgment
that's why the law gives the
responsibility to Congress I urge
support of this resolution and I yield
back
gentleman from New York reserves
gentleman from Texas is recognized the
speaker at this point I'll continue to
reserve until chairman Engel was
prepared to close
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized I yield one
minute to the gentleman from Michigan
mr. Kildee the gentleman from Michigan
is recognized Thank You mr. speaker and
I thank my my friend mr. Engel for
yielding I'm troubled by aspects of this
debate I think it's fine that we have
different views but to hear some on the
other side characterize the position of
those who support this resolution is
somehow not loving the country as much
as they do when it's our country as well
that we pledge to defend it's the same
veterans on this side of the aisle that
put themselves in harm's way as the
veterans on the other side of the aisle
there's no distinction
in the battlefield we love our children
and want to defend them as much as we
know you do as well so let's stop the
demagoguery regarding patriotism this
comes to a simple question and it's not
even a question as to whether or not
there was justification to take out mr.
Salamone because clearly there was the
question is who gives the justification
who authorizes military action in this
country we can all have our opinions but
we ought to consult the Constitution
that best yield the gentleman 15
additional seconds gentleman may
continue
thank you we ought to consult the
Constitution which clearly vests that
authority in this Congress we ought not
fear that Authority and outsource it to
the executive branch we ought to embrace
that Authority and be willing to make
that decision and follow the
Constitution I think with jamun
gentleman from Texas continue to reserve
the gentleman from New York is
recognized I now yield one minute to the
gentlewoman from the District of
Columbia Ms Norton the gentlewoman from
the District of Columbia is recognized I
thank my good friend for yielding
Congress has long been absent without
leave from its constitutional
responsibility to authorize war before
it occurs
from Vietnam to Iran the verdict on the
War Powers Act is clear you lose it if
you do not use it Congress checks at
outside presidential power but it's
failed to exercise its own advice and
consent power on war Iran has stepped
back for now from the brink of war
following the killing of general
Soleimani but a strong but bipartisan
69% of the American people say that war
with Iran is now more likely no wonder
considering that we have Justin deployed
15
thousand more troops to the region
trying to get answers after the fact as
Congress did in yesterday's briefing
yielded frustration not answers
unchecked executive power unbalances the
safeguards against arbitrary power the
framers built into our constitution with
passage of today's resolution we will
reclaim that balance by reading certain
Congress into decisions to go to war
from Texas continue to reserve from New
York is recognized
ok I now yield one minute to a very
valued member of the Foreign Affairs
Committee the chairman of the
Subcommittee on the Middle East North
Africa and international terrorism the
gentleman from Florida mr. Deutsch
gentleman from Florida is recognized Mr
Speaker I rise in support of this War
Powers Resolution and I thank my
colleague from Michigan representative
slackin for leading this effort today to
assert Congress's rightful authority and
to defend our solemn constitutional duty
none of us want to see our brave men and
women sent into another war to be clear
this vote is not about telling the
administration and the president can't
defend this country my colleagues know
that they understand it I strongly
reject any implication that somehow by
supporting this resolution we don't take
our national security and the safety of
our servicemembers seriously to the
contrary
nothing we do today limits the ability
to respond to a real and imminent threat
or defend this country and our interest
to assert so is simply false and it is
reckless
today we're telling the president that
there is if there is a serious threat to
the United States our national security
requires that a solemn decision is made
to engage you in u.s. forces the elected
representatives of this body have to
have the John may continue I thank my
friend the Elector representatives of
the American people need to have that
case made to them
Congress needs to have a robust debate
about any authorization for the use of
military force I urge my colleagues to
vote yes I urge my colleagues to uphold
the Constitution and I yield back does
the gentleman from Texas continue to
reserve gentleman from New York is
recognized I yield one minute one minute
to the gentleman from Florida mr. Goetz
gentleman from Florida is recognized I
take a back seat to no member of this
body when it comes to defending the
president
this resolution offers no criticism of
the president no critique it doesn't
criticize the president's attack on
soleimani matter of fact this resolution
doesn't even say soleimani 's name in it
yet it does articulate our very robust
basis for self-defense at times even
preemptory self-defense to defend our
troops and it also articulates our
non-delegable duty as members of the
United States Congress to speak to
matters of war and peace
I represent more troops than any other
member of this body I buried one of them
earlier today at Arlington and that
sergeant died at patriot and a hero if
the members of our armed services have
the courage to go and fight and die in
these wars as Congress we ought to have
the courage to vote forum or against
them and I think it's ludicrous to
suggest that we are impairing the troops
from doing their job by not doing our
job articulated in the Constitution to
speak to these matters of war and peace
I support the president killing
Soleimani was the right decision but
engaging in another forever war in the
Middle East would be the wrong decision
and that's why I'm voting for this
resolution and I yield back
gentleman from New York reserves does
the gentleman from Texas continue to
reserve
the gentleman from New York is
recognized I yield one minute to the
gentleman from Massachusetts mr. Moulton
gentleman from Massachusetts is
recognized mr. speaker the system of
checks and balances is broken
last week's air strike proves it after
the strike the administration produced a
vague document that attempts justifying
America's porshe to the brink
war mr. chairman I fought in a war
started by a president with faults and
trumped-up intelligence we cannot let
this president do the same Americans
deserve to read the Declassified report
so they can judge for themselves whether
the strike was worth the risk they'll
find an administration shooting from the
hip with no strategy to deal with Iran
it's time for Congress to lead and
exercise the authority the founders gave
us in article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution it's time to tell the
president he cannot send our troops to
war with Iran without a strategy and
without the consent of their
representatives I yield back the
gentleman from New York reserves does
the gentleman from Texas continue to
reserve the gentleman from New York is
recognized I yield one minute to the
gentleman from Maryland mr. brown
the gentleman from Maryland is
recognized Thank You mr. speaker
President Trump strategy to counter Iran
has failed he's allowed Iran to restart
its nuclear weapons program disrupted
our operations countering Isis continues
to undermine our relationship with NATO
allies and has led America to the brink
of a new and unnecessary war as someone
who served in Iraq I understand the cost
of war how our soldiers put their lives
on the line and the impact these
decisions have on military families our
founders entrusted Congress with the
responsibility to declare war Congress
owes it to the American people in our
men and women in uniform to carry out
that responsibility it's time for
Congress to declare that war with Iran
is not in the best interests of the
American people it is time for Congress
to repeal the 2002 AUMF and dramatically
restrict the 2001 AUMF and until we can
do that we must prevent the president
from unilaterally committing the United
States to yet another war in the Middle
East and I yield back
gentleman from New York reserves does
the gentleman from Texas continue to
reserve
I was figure I'm pleased to yield two
minutes to the gentleman from
Pennsylvania mr. Kelly the gentleman
from Pennsylvania is recognized Thank
You mr. speaker and I thank the chairman
I was sitting my office and watching
this debate and I began to wonder who it
is that we're actually debating against
or what it is that we're debating
against and I think back to the killing
of Osama bin Laden when we stood
together as a United States and saying
this was the right thing to do at the
right time because it would save lives
the only thing when you regret is that
we didn't do it sooner when we had a
chance to take him out but we delay
because we weren't sure I've gone back
in red with President Obama said and he
says I made this decision on my own
yet today we stand in the people's house
if we're worried more about the loss of
an election of 20 and 2020 than the loss
of American lives in the continued loss
of lives around the world by one of the
worst terrorists of all times and we sit
here and try to pretend this charade is
what we're really concerned about is
giving too much power to this president
this is a president who acts boldly this
is a president who carried out a strike
that was so precise so strategic nothing
else was hurt except the car in which
that terrorist was riding in and yet we
sit here today and say our problem in
America isn't terrorists around the
world our problem is anime America is we
have a president who's too damn strong
the rest of the world knows today that
our enemies certainly do fear us because
they know there's a deterrent in the
White House and our friends and allies
know that America will always be there
will always be there if we say we're
going to be there and we will always
stand up for the values that this
country has always stood for to have
this bait debate tonight and this
resolution is not about securing America
or making America safer this is about
taking powers away from the president
United States and we can call this
anything we want to say not just this
president but any present in the future
my god are you kidding me are you
kidding me this the people's house and
our biggest responsibility is protecting
our American citizens and we're having
this debate tonight please do not tell
me this is about
taking away the authorization for
military force this is about taking away
powers out as time goes by we've had
they could I yield back the gentleman
from Texas reserves gentleman from New
York is recognized you know again I
think it would be helpful if people's
motives where patriotism wasn't
questioned I now yield two minutes to
the gentleman from Illinois mr.
Schneider gentleman from Illinois is
recognized Thank You mr. Speaker I rise
today in strong support of the War
Powers Resolution introduced by my
colleague from Michigan congresswoman
ELISA Slaton soleimani was an evil man a
terrorist a war criminal
no one should mourn his demise but that
doesn't change the question of who has
the authority to take our nation into
war it is Congress and only Congress
that is endowed with the most solemn
duty to decide if when and where to
commit our nation to war at the same
time as commander-in-chief it is
incumbent upon our president to ensure
that the fine men and women who serve in
our military are only sent into harm's
way
after careful deliberation and tasked
with missions that protect and further
America's interests and reflect the
values and high moral standing of our
nation our country's founders in their
foresight provided us a robust and
resilient constitutional republic and
representative government they wisely
understood that taking a nation to war
should not be a unilateral decision by a
single person but a considered decision
by the people's elected representatives
this administration does not have
congressional authorization for use of
military force or a declaration of war
against Iran ultimately any sustained
action against Iran requires
congressional approval today's
resolution reflects the intentions of
our founders it makes clear the
president must seek authorization from
Congress for any extended military
engagement with Iran without restricting
his ability to protect the nation from
in an intimate imminent threat I have
the honor of representing Naval Station
Great Lakes where every enlisted sailor
receives his or her be
training I am the proud father of a son
serving in our Navy we owe it to these
Americans each one a volunteer answering
the call to serve our country to protect
this Constitution and live up to the
expectations of our founders the
American people do not want an
unnecessary war with Iran today's
resolution prevents President Trump from
unilaterally or impulsively starting one
I urge my colleagues to vote yes I yield
back
gentleman from New York reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized say
mr. speaker I'm pleased to yield one
minute to the gentleman from Wisconsin a
man who served on the battlefield in
Iraq gentleman from Wisconsin recognized
thank mr. chairman I've actually it
takes a lot to get me to come down to
these things but I have been deeply
troubled by some of the rhetoric I've
been hearing about this in fact I was
deeply troubled after yesterday when my
colleagues many of them left a
classified briefing only to immediately
and recklessly trash the quality of
intelligence they received and in some
cases suggests there was no imminent
threat from Soleimani
to suggest that would require you to
ignore the death of Americans recently
in Iraq as well as ignore the history of
Seoul amantes campaign of terror across
the Middle East and we learned this
weekend while this body was still in
recess and before anyone had reviewed
any of the classified information that
it was the intention of my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle to introduce
this flawed War Powers Resolution
without having even seen any of the
underlying intelligence this suggests
that this is not a serious that's know
30 seconds
gentleman may continue this is not a
serious effort this is a political
effort that will have the practical
effect only of undermining our military
deterrent in the Middle East which for
the first time in a long time is
actually stronger and I think this does
a service not only to our personnel in
the region but ultimately to the Iranian
P
and what the Iranian regime fears more
than anything else more than the
American military and the president
United States is its own people and that
is the reason sulla Monty's death squads
have gone down Iranian civilians in the
streets and we look forward to the day
when the Iranian people can be free of
their evil barbarous reckless regime and
I applaud the administration's actions
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized may I
inquire how much time I have that's four
minutes remaining
four minutes I yield one minute to the
gentleman from Colorado mr. crow
gentleman from Colorado is recognized
mr. speaker our founders vested in
Congress the solemn responsibility of
sending our sons and daughters to war I
have often heard folks say that now is
not the time to discuss the use of force
or decision to send our men and women to
fight I heard that in 2003 when I was
carrying a rifle in Baghdad I heard it
again in 2004 and 2005 and I was leading
my unit through the mountains of
Afghanistan and I am hearing it again
today in the halls of Congress in the
last 19 years more than 7,000 Americans
have given their lives in these
conflicts 53,000 had been wounded and we
have spent over four trillion dollars of
taxpayer money do not believe the
fear-mongering this resolution does
nothing to prevent the president from
protecting the nation against eminent
threats I have spent years fighting to
keep Americans safe and will continue to
do so I may have laid down my rifle but
my oath to this country indoors I will
fight to ensure that we are having a
discussion about wind to send our men
and women our sons and daughters and our
sisters and brothers into harm's way it
is time to have this debate Mr Speaker I
yield back the gentleman from New York
reserves the gentleman from Texas is
recognized the speaker at this point I'm
continue to reserve until the Chairman
is prepared to close gentleman from
Texas reserves gentleman from New York
is recognized
I now yield 30 seconds to the gentleman
from Tennessee mr. Cohen gentleman from
Tennessee is recognized thank you sir
I rise today to condemn the president's
most recent reckless actions the killing
of general Soleimani was a provocation
to war that made Americans left safe for
years and maybe decades to come the
president has put his own ego over the
strategic interest and safety of
Americans when he has accomplished with
these actions is to make soleimani so
limini a martyr for a generation of
militant middle-eastern foes that we
have it is united the Iranian people not
against their government but against us
it is the responsibility of the
President gentlemen additional 30
seconds gentleman may continue
it's responsibly the president Congress
to keep us safe and the founding fathers
knew the collective wisdom of the
people's representatives was better at
doing that than one person I just
visited the skiff and there is still not
any report on any imminent danger claim
that might have been made the American
people in Congress deserve to know what
the threat allegedly was given the
inevitability of Iranian retaliation the
two greatest powers Congress has is
impeachment and declarations of war we
are here today on both of those issues
because of a reckless lawless and
impetuous president I yield back the
balance of my time
gentleman from New York reserves members
were reminder refrain from engaging in
personalities toward the president does
the gentleman from Texas continue to
reserve gentleman from New York is
recognized I now yield one minute to
very distinguished gentlemen from
Foreign Affairs Committee mr. Meeks of
New York and for how much time one
minute gentleman from New York is
recognized the president should not be
able to commit the u.s. recklessly and
flagrantly to war that is the reason
there are constitutional mandated checks
and balances the president escalated
hostilities with Iran and did not
demonstrate any
threat nor strategy as to why he clearly
did not make our country safer quite the
opposite
it is not a sign of strength as some of
my colleagues suggests it is they say
was an unchecked sign of more disarray
and lack of strategic thinking we have
seen what happens when we don't have a
plan for what comes next when we take
out a bad actor without thinking through
long-term consequences we have lost too
much blood and tears and treasure to
ever allow that to happen again I
support and employ my colleagues to
support this resolution for the sake in
this for the sake and the state of
future generations I love this country
this is the greatest country in the
world because we have checks and
balances I yield back
Irv's the gentleman from Texas is
recognized I continue to reserve my time
gentleman from Texas reserves gentleman
from New York is recognized yeah I
reserve my right to close gentleman from
New York reserves gentleman from Texas
is recognized mr. speaker now recognized
a severe day for 30 seconds gentleman
from West Virginia is recognized Indiana
is recognized thank you and mr. speaker
just got a couple of words I'd like to
remind this body about and I've heard a
lot of talk about patriotism and I gave
this arm in Vietnam and I've got a lot
of good friends whose names are on the
Vietnam Wall so don't talk to me about
patriotism and how much I love this
country
when we're standing here debating an
issue that we all know is not going
anywhere and the last thing I would say
to you is while I was serving in Vietnam
there were many occasions when I didn't
have the ability to do what I thought
was necessary I just say to you that
this body couldn't make up their mind
where they want to be in that war or not
and I suggest we get with the right
program
and do it now Thank You Jennifer from
Texas is recognized speaker I'm prepared
to close
and I yield myself the balance and I
speak on strongly in favor of exercising
our article one authorities for matter
as grave as war and peace but the fact
is we are not at war with Iran and the
president is not trying to start a war
with Iran I met with the president
earlier today he told me that if this
resolution passes
he will take all of his power to
negotiate with Iran off the table and
that is a war saying that we could do
yesterday he called for making a deal
that allows for Iran to thrive and
prosper prosper the president is making
the choice to move towards de-escalation
the premise of this resolution is flawed
because we are not engaged in
hostilities with Iran the president is
not trying to start hostilities with
Iran and despite this public
proclamation by our president my
colleagues are trying to claim that the
president still wants to go to war I
deeply regret that my colleagues are not
serious enough about exercising article
1 authorities to pursue regular order on
such a serious question we've had no
hearings in the House Foreign Affairs
Committee since these events transpired
there was no foreign affairs committee
markup of this legislation I received
text of this legislation only two hours
before the Rules Committee meeting last
night on a War Powers Resolution
debating issues of war and peace is
perhaps our most important
responsibility as members of Congress
and yet this legislation dropped last
night without committee consideration as
required by the War Powers Resolution if
my colleagues were serious about article
1 as
say they are this will be a joint
resolution with a force of law instead
it is a house concurrent resolution that
will never go to the President's desk
let me translate what that means for the
American people listening today today we
are voting on a press release a press
statement this is a political statement
for a left-wing domestic audience but
they are not the only ones watching mr.
speaker Iran is watching and its proxies
are watching and what they see is a
divide in America the does not fully
support the ability of our
commander-in-chief to respond to
imminent threats to Americans Churchill
warned against appeasement when the dark
clouds of fascism and the Third Reich
swept in my father's war weakness
invites aggression he said and as
President Reagan said peace through
strength I believe in these ideals in
these axioms and last May has reported
that Salman ëwhat met with Iraqi
militias in Baghdad and told them to
quote prepare the wars prepare the
proxies for war
salamati would still be waging that
proxy war they wore that he was
escalating an American was killed less
than two weeks ago and four American
soldiers were injured and our embassy in
Baghdad was attacked under Salman T's
orders what more do we need what more
evidence do we need to spin and let's
talk about the fact he's a designated
terrorist under the Obama administration
importantly the president told me today
that Salman II was planning to blow up
our embassy
I need no further proof or evidence than
that or intelligence than that from the
president United States and what if the
President had not acted let's assume
that what is the president and by the
way some on the other side of the aisle
were criticizing him for not responding
after our embassy was attacked what if
he did not act what if Salman he made it
back to Tehran to meet with the
Ayatollah to give the green light to
carry out the plot to attack our
soldiers and diplomats in Iraq what if
the Americans were killed
what if they killed our soldiers and
diplomats where they successfully
stormed our American Embassy and held
our Marines and diplomats hostage like
they did in 1979 when this whole reign
of terror started with Jimmy Carter in
the White House how would the critics of
the president respond then if we had
done nothing
how would America the American people
respond how were the Gold Star Mothers
responds no miss the president this
president did the right thing to take
out this threat they killed so many
Americans I've been to too many funerals
of many of us in this chamber have and
many of those those soldiers were killed
at the hands the bloody hands of Salman
II and so those many
Aaron sees family still greeted a we
agree for them and since 1979 Iran is
presided over a reign of terror in the
region and for over two decades Salman
II has been the mastermind of terror and
the world is safer today with Adam and
let me just conclude by saying now is
not the time now it's not the time to
divide this nation and play into the
propaganda of Iran now's the time not to
tire commander-in-chief's hands now is
the time to support our men and women in
uniform and with that I urge my
colleagues to oppose this resolution and
I yield back the balance of my time the
gentleman from Texas yields back the
balance of his time the gentleman from
New York is recognized mr. speaker this
body has to make a decision about
whether we're going to stand up for our
constitutional responsibilities or just
subordinate ourselves in the to the
executive branch when it comes to War
Powers we're two decades into the 21st
century our country has been at war
almost that entire time and then a day
goes by that I don't wish we could have
some of those decisions back especially
because we see those measures we passed
in 2001 and 2002 are still being used to
justify sending American men and women
into harm's way we could stand here all
day and say well your side let this
happen when you were in charge well you
didn't say anything when this President
did that I don't disagree it's been a
collective failure on the part of this
body that we've given away our authority
on War Powers that we haven't done
enough to grapple with the issue well I
hope today will not be the end of our
efforts to make progress on debating
Congress's War Powers if the president
thinks he needs to use military force he
needs to come to Congress and make the
case and let us vote on it
I urge my friends on both sides of the
aisle support this resolution this is
the beginning of Congress taking back
its authority thank you gentleman from
New York yields back the balance of his
time
all time for debate has expired and
pursuant to house rules 781
the previous question is ordered on the
concurrent resolution as amended the
question is on adoption of the
concurrent resolution those in favor say
aye
those opposed no the eyes have it the
concurrent resolution is agreed to and
the nays and nays are requested
those favoring a vote by the yeas and
nays will rise a sufficient number
having risen the yeas and nays are
ordered
members will record their votes by
electronic device
pursuant to Clause 9 of rule 20 this
15-minute vote on adoption of the house
concurrent resolution 83 will be
followed by a five-minute vote on the
motion to suspend the rules and pass HR
5 0 7 8 this is a 15-minute vote
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on this vote the yeas are 224 and the
nays are 194 the current resolution is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
pursuant to Clause 8 of rule 20 the
unfinished business is the vote on the
motion of the gentlewoman from New York
mr. Las West to suspend the rules and
pass HR 5:07 a as amended on which the
yeas and nays are ordered
the clerk will report the title HR 5078
a bill to amend a small business act to
provide free entry entrepreneurship
counseling and training services for
incarcerated individuals and for other
purposes the question is will the house
suspend the rules and pass the bill as
amended members will record their votes
by electronic device this is a
five-minute vote
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]